[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez conscience que vous êtes
complètement siphonnés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lalalalalalalalala
je vous le dis y'a une xbox a gagné
cette partie jacek bak
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
m
on est quand même une émission médias ça
commençait d'xbox a gagné tout et après
il se met du canada dry
[Applaudissements]
santiago lange
bonjour loyers depuis je vois plus rien
on parlera bien sûr télé 1 dans cette
émission
ouais deux minutes tu veux pas de par
tout ce qu'elle porte à la halle à 17
c'est bon c'est à dire mais vous avez
conscience que vous êtes complètement
siphonnés montpellier jean michel maire
qui va bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gates a atterri à east africa
[Applaudissements]
cd
à
[Musique]